what's your like your main source of
income these days right now I think it's
like mostly every Creator that's on this
program but Snapchat oh I've heard about
Snapchat yeah how many views do your
videos get there anywhere between 50 to
100 million views 50 to 100 million yeah
tell me what the [__] some days it's
like 300 million and so Snapchat they
put ads in between the stores I heard
the CPM there's [__] crazy it's
amazing it's the only uh platform that
actually pays the creators so are you
doing like seven digits plus from
Snapchat
making good money I've been trying to
I've had like companies reach out
they're like hey we think your podcast
would do really good on Snapchat well
you're thinking of a snap show but even
stories are monetized
what is going on over there